[Music]
so today we are making pizza but there
is one role
we cannot make any waste i'm ari i make
environmental content here at buzzfeed
and i try my best to live zero waste
i'm a pretty basic chef i make like a
lot of plant-based meals
i have never made a pizza and i'm going
to be asking you lots of questions
pizza is very simple it's flour water
yeast and salt
and sugar i think we can make little
waste as possible
food waste is not necessarily bad but
for the sake of this challenge we're
going to try to make
no waste if you want to learn more about
sustainability and healthy living check
out good fool's youtube channel
[Music]
i just want to shop for myself here not
bad
not bad so i'm thinking about making a
simple
veggie pizza topped with vegan parmesan
and some ginger krispies i think because
i'm making a pizza without cheese
i really gotta hit you with some other
flavors
i think flower is there i'm going to
make margarita pizza because
it's such a simple ingredient simple
ingredients means
i don't think i will create a lot of
trash we need oregon
oh i found one without a sticker oh okay
i'm going to make pizza dough using
bread flour
it has more gluten so it has a kind of
chewy texture
so oil is something that's hard to find
zero waste
so we did end up having to purchase
glass container of oil which we can
recycle
but it's not completely zero waste
so instead of regular cheese i'm making
vegan parmesan
with cashews and nutritional yeast from
the bulk bins margarita pizza has
mozzarella cheese
mozzarella cheese it's very difficult to
make okay i think we should have more
boiling water
mother pearl so i'm gonna just buy
mozzarella cheese
if you go to cheese shop i have a
feeling they might
sell it in a bulk can i ask you a
question do you guys sell mozzarella
cheese
mozzarella like pre-packaged um not
pre-packaged like
something yeah it's from our deli we'll
package it oh cool
we have a container we asked the shop
staff
they were a little bit hesitant people
aren't really used to
you asking to put things in your own
container
but as long as you're friendly and nice
it usually works out and that's exactly
what we did
we got it good job
we are back and i'm so excited to make
dough i've never made dough yay
so first we're gonna activate east
and unfortunately here is our count of
one waste
oh okay you can already see like bubble
we are going to put salt and olive oil
for
the yeast mixture right in there oh and
i can really smell it
so we have to knead it in order to get
that nice
chew it's really wet
so like what you're looking for is when
you poke the finger it should be
bouncing back
this is very satisfying i feel like i
got
extra skin
that was a good jump yeah this is gross
ball
so i want to get a new ball with olive
oil
and rest it for a few hours we're going
to just put in a
warm comfy place for our baby
so cute
we got our dough so we are going to
punch the dough release the gas we shake
it
yeah so it creates a bunch of gas inside
so you kind of want to release the gas
oh
this is so satisfying and we are going
to reshape it
we really suggest we are making two
pizza
so i'm going to cut in half we are going
to like reshape the dough
kind of clothes the thing you just like
want to make really cute
wow yours is so nice our doughboys
yay so we're gonna just rest it we get
to take a nap now one hour nap
[Music]
i made pizza before but i've never made
pizza sauce like with fresh tomato most
recipes for pizza sauce
call for a can of tomato sauce
and so we're trying to just take the
tomatoes and make our own sauce
and i'm hoping that it'll taste good but
i'm a little worried
all washed we did it we're cutting
tomato half
we are going to call this olive oil and
put
salt and pepper what do you think we can
do to have like that rich
tomato paste flavor if we roast it low
and slow
it will develop kind of concentrated
flavor
so i'm hoping salt day over here do you
want to do it
so now we are going to roast the
tomatoes
now we're going to make your cheese i
want to see
how you make it because i've never made
vegan cheese before so i'm going to be
using
nooch which is a deactivated yeast
from molasses and it's really high in
like b vitamins it has like a really
deep
cheesy flavor and cashews garlic powder
and salt to make our
parmesan
i guess we'll try it yeah oh wow
it's good it almost tastes like cheese
[Laughter]
these are my toppings and this is my
ingredient
oh just one cheese this one
i'm gonna be sauteing all these
[Music]
vegetables
i'm done oh wow can i
help you oh if you want yeah yeah food
waste i don't
worry as much about because it's an
organic matter
and it decomposes over time whereas
plastic can take up to 450 years to
break down
so i really try to avoid plastic because
that really stays in our environment and
also
only nine percent of plastic actually
gets recycled
and now i'm crying because i'm cutting
onions you are so like really
you know try not to make plastic guys
[Music]
i'm going to make tomato sauce and we
are going to make the topping
i sauteed the onion and this is roasted
tomato we roasted at 300
for one hour it's gonna be our pizza
sauce
i hope it's enough for both of us i hope
so too we'll have to divvy it up
right i hope it works
it's still missing a little bit that
deep flavor
but it has kind of sweet and like fresh
flavor i like so we can do it we don't
need a canned tomato
[Music]
now we're gonna shape the dough so put
some flour on the surface
take the dough ooh it feels even more
different than before
it's like more fragile or something it's
cool so you're gonna
push and kind of shape like a pizza
shape
so i'm kind of doing like ripple my
pizza has
a little bit thicker crust on the
outside so i'm stretching
center part more than the outer side
make it fancy
let's put the topping yay let's dress
these pizzas
looks like pizza sauce i'm pretty proud
of us i'm going to put
mozzarella cheese okay i'm gonna put on
my toppings i have quite a lot of
toppings
and we'll see if it breaks apart in the
oven oh
nice you can just drop it
okay okay that's not so bad now we're
gonna put in the oven
i'm heating baking sheet upside down so
creating
really hot surface it's kind of like
searing steak
oh it looks so good a beautiful baby
it's out of the oven
can i say that pizza is out from the
oven i'm going to garnish with fresh
basil you want to put basil
after pizza is baked because you kind of
want to have like
nice fresh basil flavor the finishing
touch
yay our pizza looks beautiful in
my pizza it's just like very simple
straightforward pizza but this is how i
like it so at the beginning i was really
nervous about making pizza from scratch
because i haven't done that before
but it was just so fun to make with rie
and she's so knowledgeable
i think the pizzas turned out really
great so i'm really impressed with the
amount of waste that we created
zero waste just means trying to send as
little as possible to landfill it
doesn't mean trying to be
perfect and not making any trash because
that's impossible i'm excited to try i
have no idea what this tastes like
let's eat yes so let's bring our friends
over
and have them taste it i made a
classic margarita we're all just
watching
i love a good fluffy crust
[Music]
i love it it's so fresh the tomatoes
really fresh very good pizza
very good great job great job guys well
done pizza
so no pizza box i guess
you